[Music]
nathan's in london ontario did you know
you were hero nathan already called your
hero once because i got the name wrong
from the other guy but anyway what's up
man how are you
i'm doing great how are you great hero
what's up
um so i'm gonna be turning 22 this year
and i have 21 000 dollars saved in my
savings way to go um
i haven't invested it or done anything
with it and i'm going to be graduating
community college pretty soon good for
you um what's your degree in the winter
time um electrical engineering
technology wow what are you going to do
after you graduate go on for further ed
or are you going to go into the
workplace
um right away into the workplace um i'm
pretty uncertain if i want to
go further ahead in education or not so
i'm just going to work to make money to
pay for um university if i decide to go
to it i like you um
um
my question is
when should i start investing my money
or start to save for a down payment for
a house um i'm just kind of pretty lost
in what to do next in my life
financially since i'm going to be
graduating soon um that's mainly my
question well you have done a great job
so far sir
you're way ahead of the typical guy out
there your age you've done really smart
way to go congratulations you are hero
see i was right there i was a prophet
that's right but uh so so really cool so
here's what we're gonna do as soon as
you step out of school let's start
walking what we call our baby steps have
you ever heard kristy and i talk about
those
yes okay so tell me what the first thing
you need to do is
um
get an emergency fund yeah you have no
debt right
yeah and then have no debt and then um
do you have any doubt i have three to
six no i do not have okay so you're
already at baby step three so three to
six you got it right you dialed it in so
we're gonna set some of your 20 000
aside as your emergency fund
and then we're going to set some of it
aside to start saving towards your house
and then you can sit down with
smartvestor pro or an investment advisor
in your area we don't have them in
canada so you can find an investment
advisor in your area that has the heart
of a teacher and you can
start your investing right baby step
four
while you're saving for your house
all right any idea what kind of money
you're going to be making
um it's about 78 000 a year um i'm a
pretty motivated person i think
i have the drive to make more than that
by going to university afterwards but um
i'm kind of
um you know thinking about if i need a
degree or not to actually
get make the money i'd like to so i'm
just going to work for a year and see
what i feel and you know what during
that year if you want to not do baby
step four not do retirement instead pile
up cash because we not might want the
money for um for a university move
uh that would probably be a good idea
because honestly you're a better
investment than a retirement account is
and you're not sure right now you're not
sure what you're going to do because
you're young and you're in transitional
years of your life so yeah you can pile
up money and then you can use it for
college use it for university use it for
a house you'll have it for whatever you
decide to do so cool well done sir very
well done